beispielsweise mal denke oh ich will
doch da hinten hin öffnete meine lieben
freunde und herzlich willkommen zu einer
weiteren folge der minecraft facts heute
am dienstag ich habe ich ja gesagt die
facts kommen jetzt nur noch dienstags
freitags die command kommen und
allgemein bei mit unglaublich viele bahn
zugesendet werden und unglaublich wenige
interessante effekt sind irgendwelche
interessanten quiz könnte mir die gerne
mit mir die gerne in die kommentare
schreiben es ist übrigens gerade extrem
früh ist es gerade sieben uhr und ich
nehme dieses video auf weil ich gleich
den ganzen tag uni habe und ich wollte
heute unbedingt noch die packs aufnehmen
deswegen würde ich mich freuen wenn ihr
bis zum ende dran bleibt und wir fangen
direkt an mit fact nummer weg nummer
eins ist eine recht simple sache die mir
beim spielen von minecraft leben
aufgefallen ist und zwar es ist ja ganz
normal ich nehme einen bruch steiner
seinen kumpels down und zwei stücke
darunter dann kann ich mir eine kleine
schaufel machen wenn ich das ganze
allerdings mit einem normalen stein
versuche also mit einem stein mit einem
bruchstein den ich im ofen zu einem
normalen stone halt quasi gebracht
transformiert habe keine ahnung genau
wie ich das nennen soll jedenfalls kann
man daraus sich keine normale schaufel
machen das geht nur mit einem bruchstein
mit einem normalen stein geht es nicht
ich weiß nicht woran es liegt weil es
doch eigentlich stein schaufel heißt und
minecraft das sieht es auch schon
darunter stone schaufel und nicht
irgendwie cobblestone schaufel und auch
nicht die bruchstein schaufel sondern
das heißt stein schaufel aber wirklich
mit einem stein kann man das ganze nicht
machen ich versteh's nicht es ist
eigentlich eine mega kuriose sache dass
das nicht geht und eventuell bis es auch
schon viele beziehungsweise haben es
unterschwellig wahrgenommen
aber so wirklich gedanken darüber habe
ich mir das noch nie gemacht
das ist mega creepy übrigens meine
stimme ist ein bisschen im eimer
irgendwie bin ich von diesen ganzen
tweets bei twitter das alemannia ich bin
krank ich krank bin ich irgendwie auch
krank geworden immer zwei wird mit
zugesendet von kell games und zwar
schreibt er dass ein
ob das so eingesparte irgend welchen
teppichen also es müssen nicht mal
irgendwie die gleichen teppiche sein
sondern es können noch komplett von den
farben her komplett unterschiedliche
teppiche sein denn ein mops eingesperrt
ist wie beispielsweise ein skelett ich
glaube bei einem schwein schal geht es
nicht mehr weil das schwein hinterher
laufen kann meine ich jedenfalls kann
ich hier ganz normal rüber springen
allerdings dass skeletten nicht und das
zeige ich euch jetzt einfach mal wenn
ich mich in den games 0 versetzte und
zwar normalerweise schießt mich jetzt
irgendwie das skelett und dann wenn ich
mich weiter weg bewege kommt das skelett
doch immer mehr in meine richtung
allerdings bleibt das da hinten einfach
stehen weil das nicht daraus kann
das ist einfach so eine genau so eine
sache wenn ich hier bin und es mir
wieder abschieden hier hinten kannst
mich auch noch abschließen aber wenn es
dann hinterher laufen geht das ganze
hier
es kam mir auf jeden fall nicht
hinterherlaufen genau das gleiche kann
ich euch beispielsweise auch mal eben
mit einem zombie zeigen seht ihr da drin
ist jetzt ein zombie der fokussiert mich
zwar an aber der kann dann nicht um wenn
ich hier den zombie serie der kann hier
ganz normal rumlaufen
den kann ich da noch ganz normal hier
einfach eben umbringen aber der zombie
da wird nichts machen außer halt wenn
ich mich irgendwie mal zu ihm hin
bewegen dann wird er mich natürlich
dadurch boxen aber der kann da nicht
drüber springen uns was das genau die
gleiche sache wie beispielsweise auch
mit den fans ist was ich mir vorgestellt
hab' mit den zäunen das ist ja auch so
wenn ich 1000 stellen und darauf den
teppich dann kann ich da ganz einfach
drauf springen obwohl das eigentlich gar
nicht funktioniert und genau das gleiche
ist auch damit quasi mit diesem mops
dass sich die damit einsperren kann so
freunde effekt nummer drei ist eine
sache die mir selber mal aufgefallen ist
beziehungsweise habe ich mich gefragt ob
das ganze funktioniert und zwar setze
ich jetzt mal ein schwein und einen
tripper hier rein
die sind ja jetzt beide quasi hier in
diesem in diesem käfig drin quasi auf
einem block und ich habe mich einfach so
gefragt ob ein blitz ein blitz
verwandelt ja ein schwein in einen
zombie pacman oder antrieb an einen
geladenen kripo ob ein blitz auch zwei
mops zum verwandeln bringen kann oder ob
jeder mob immer einen einzelnen bits
benötigt deswegen stelle ich mich jetzt
einfach mal rein schreibe in den tschad
zusammen lightning bolt und ihr seht
schon ein blitz kann beide mops zusammen
verhandeln also es ist nicht so dass ein
blitz nur den keeper geht und nur der
körper verwandelt sich in der schweiz
bleibt gleich sondern es ist einfach so
die müssen
ist das denn fahrrad seine freunde der
krieg ist einfach an dem blitz schaden
bz was an dem feuer verreckt aber der
fake beinhaltet quasi null
beziehungsweise sagt einfach nur das 1 1
1 ein mob kann sich auch verwandeln wenn
durch den blitz auch ein anderer mobben
verwandelt wird ich hoffe ich konnte
euch zeigen guckst du blöd ist eine
wundervolle morgen da sitz ich mich doch
erst mal in mein boot und nene euch den
fake nummer vier und zwar ändert perlen
einem boot geworfen teleportieren einen
nur aus dem boot raus und zwar ändern
kann man ja das sieht echt so geil aus
mit dem shader mit der sonne die dadurch
schimmert und mit dem ich leben kann ja
ender perl nur im gaylord 0 werfen
deswegen bin ich auch ein game zu null
und wenn ich mir jetzt beispielsweise
mal denke oh ich will dass da hinten hin
deswegen hab ich noch mehr boote dabei
sei wenn ich jetzt sage ja komm ich will
dahin appelle hinwerfen
dann fliege ich quasi nur aus dem boot
raus mein boot fährt ganz normal weiter
und ich selber bin hier aber schaltet
die ender perle ist dann einfach so wie
wenn ich einfach nicht kurz ins mikro
aus dem boden raus zu kommen und ich
bekomme noch den ganz normalen inter
perlen schaden und zwar ganz einfach ich
zeig euch nochmal ich weiter ich kann
den appell einfach mal nach oben werfen
ich gehe einfach aus dem boot haus habe
jetzt meine zweieinhalb herzen schaden
gekommen oder so und schaut euch das mal
an mit dieser sonne lieder so durch die
berge durch und hoffe dass ich immer ab
schleife wegen im shaker aber ich find's
einfach unglaublich schön mit dem shader
zu spielen das sieht einfach so
unfassbar cool aus aber ich denke ich
habe euch den effekt 42 shop.com habe
ich den text viel ganz gut dargestellt
also wenn in einem boot sitzt und eine
ende perle werft dann fliegt er nicht
dahin wo die appelle hingeworfene
sondern ihr geht quasi aus dem boden
bekommen schaden macht also keinen sinn
übrigens freundin während ich hier
gerade den fünften fact aufbauen da
vorne ist schon wieder so ein häuschen
ihr wisst doch davon habe ich euch den
beau zwecks gezeigt da hinten bin ich
irgendwo eschborn
wenn euch der sieht gefällt habt ihr
hier wieder den sie so freund effekt
nummer fünf besagt dass es glätte
hölzerne knöpfe aktivieren können zwar
da seht ihr schon ich habe hier so eine
kleine wand aufgebaut mit so
hölzernen buttons einfach und wenn einer
davon aktiviert wird ist hinter jedem
einen tnt das heißt dass tnt explodiert
das habe ich ganz einfach so gemacht
dass wenn ich jetzt die skelette
hinsetze und die gleich einen abschießen
von diesen schaltern das dann
hundertprozentig dass auch daran
erkennen könnt das einfach ein tnt in
die luft fliegt ich stelle mich jetzt
nicht einfach als zielscheibe hin
ich habe mir auch ganz
selbstverständliche komplette diamant
rüstung angezogen gehe jetzt in den
games 0
und wenn ihr eine explosion hört erst
mal die skelette fokussiere mich jetzt
und wenn ihr jetzt eine explosion hat
heißt es dass ein spread dieses
natürlich ein bisschen kaka weil das
jetzt einfach entzückt ist da habt ihr
auch schon die explosion gehört und das
bedeutet einfach dass ein skelett gerade
mit dem pfeil wiederbeleben soll jetzt
bin ich hier wieder jetzt dem er durch
gibt worden bin ich bin im arsch der
welt dabei dahinter richtet dort und da
habe ich mein kleines display aufgebaut
was jetzt völlig zerbombten ihr habt
euch diese sache gerade jedenfalls
gesehen dadurch dass ich wirklich keinen
schalter gedrückt habe einfach dass die
skelette mit ihrem schießen von den
pfeilen einen schalter aktiviert haben
das habt ihr ganz einfach daran gesehen
dass wir alles in die luft geflogen ist
und das war dann auch schon fängt nummer
fünf für diese folge meine lieben
freunde wenn es euch gefallen hat und je
mehr mycroft holmes wollt dann schreibt
mir welche die kommentare und zeigt es
mit einer bewertung und dann sehen wir
unter bleiben ihr müsst euch auf jeden
fall wenn ihr bock auf so was hat die
letzte den romands folge anschauen weil
dadurch ein command vorgestellt mit dem
man glaube ich mit einem command eine
komplette stadt erschaffen kann das
schon sehr geil und an dem wir uns da
wieder tschüss